hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach okay we got to UM
memory access violation last time so we
had to restart the game again what is
this oh I went back I went ask backwards
because the layout on this one is
flipped so I I skipped ahead a little
bit and just got the gas mask got out of
there I was thinking about going farther
but I said you know since everything's
randomized you never know what's gonna
happen so who knows when a big old
jump-scares gonna come my way
like right now screw you [ __ ]
go to hell you know like you you know
like you put the button alright let's
see what else awaits me in this hellhole
of a containment facility that was this
happen sometimes sometimes if you get
that memory access violation on a
particular save game and you can't get
away from it you that save game is just
Bork there's no cheating to get out of
that one
what is this is er I'm in a long series
of randomized room layouts choices
choices choices why are these doors all
open whatever you got waiting for me in
the darkness the dark isn't another one
Jesus how many oh it's a water again
how many Jesus it's another layout of
choices what are you doing to me came
have you got in store for me have I
found the one seed that's just a maze oh
good I don't want to go in there go the
other way
man it's like seriously it's just a
bunch of layout it always that connect
to each other wise going on I'm so lost
and confused but I want to hurry up a
new four but oh yeah this is this this
is the the prion thing the virus oh man
oh man I wish I had my keycard I want to
be able to go into work what is this
I've never seen this before is it just
another connecting hallway
gosh they will darken here seriously I
haven't found an actual room yet
it's just been another one I've got body
how mysterious
seriously is this took a friggin mess I
don't want to go down there
that's another maze you can't fool me
the co mega that's you more what's that
what is that it's like a door there
something is bug gel over there I can't
go in there anyway cuz it's on another
one
what the hell this happen i ha ha
guy I've losing my mind I'm never gonna
be able to backtrack because I'm just
gonna be stuck in an endless loop of
hell I can't see anything
what is this to door ah no it's an
elevator
Cheers let me out let me out let me out
let me out huh I can't
hey this is a worse seat ever there's
nothing actually here it's just all
stuff what was it here how's the
elevator I don't want to go there it's
just all endless loops of hallways hold
up let me out I want to go home I closed
it
I know where I'm going what am i doing
what am i doing oh just a little Allah
Allah none of them actually lead
anywhere they just lead off into
nothingness that goes to this go to how
do you remember this goes to the steam
gas room all right I guess I can go in
here he's not in there anyway so let's
just hurry our butts up and get on over
there what where am I there is hello
alright was there anything worth it over
here he told me there was it's another
hallway again I'm going to die in
hallways another one
Oh God did this just lead back to the
same one if it did I'm gonna I bet it
did I bet it did who did the door
Georgia oh wait no maybe he didn't I
can't him it please lead somewhere mine
a blast uncover yours I'm gonna die
swear this is unbelievable oh good
there's that thing well if I could just
find a keycard
I would be so happy cuz gosh darn it I
keep her I want to go somewhere I want
to do stuff what is it oh that's where
the two little SCP items are ah there's
a Dodge right where where I'm a baby oh
yeah I'm gonna yeah
their causal command to give me
something I don't know
spa item MasterCard yeah mastercards
barn
oh wait MasterCard is the credit card
not
oh damn it ah spawn item Omni card podge
spawn item full 5 dammit what is it
I just got this Master Card now I have a
credit card
ah ah maybe it's bond item key card
spawn item level 5 key card job ahead
maybe it's one word bond item level five
key card bought item on a key card
ah ah I'm gonna be stuck here forever
that's it you know what I know how to
solve this I know how don't look at me
I'm not cheating I'm uh I'm in a I'm in
a world of hurt and out of necessity I
must I must smoke this weed that's the
good [ __ ] man
okay I'm gonna find out what these
ding-dong damn mysterious entities of
what no that's not what I'm looking for
what am I looking for you I'm looking
for the sheet of music no no no not that
save the sheet of music I was here
before please look but I don't think
that I actually found anything like that
what the hell I'm not moving oh no oh no
resist resist resist Brotherhood no ji
round don't do it
no you can hoist it up door up today
am I still dying I'll actually want to
see what happens if I do die so let's go
back in that room there hey yeah yeah
yeah yeah get it the doors open now get
it do go write your music make some
beautiful music oh oh oh my boy
solutely class d third part this this
mate
I can see more lines popping up you're
doing great guy
keep going you're gonna finish this song
well though some hmm yes let's never go
in there again I don't see why oh there
would be what is the point of that is
that just there so that you can I don't
know what that I'm going very I'm
crouching okay there we go okay what was
the point of that
oh no let's just get our Silius EP stuff
in here
get the ring yes get the no don't get
that cuz that's the Bible of diseases or
whatever you want to call it the
encyclopedia of common diseases and then
you get them and I think the last one I
got was herpes damn that book gave me
heart rate okay anyway so we're moving
forward with our totally legitimately
gotten a level five key card we can
finally make some progress right right
after an agony a forever noose guy ah ah
one seven threes in there yeah so now we
can do some it's really dark is it just
me or is it darker than usual
it seems darker than usual I don't know
all of this is just dammit
just go what yeah that's where I was
that's where I came from
there's no way out I need to find the
prion disease cuz I want to see that one
I want to see that if I'm gonna be stuck
in purgatory forever I'm gonna see some
new stuff yeah yeah I must see some news
all right yeah let's do this
you turn into a zombie or something I
think someone said it might be a zombie
virus I don't know who is this it
unknown cloud please say you're right
anything the reason food aah
close the damn door I need some privacy
for this one okay so what do we got here
see a complex prion flora jeez do sighs
Lulu didn't ingest living humans and
okay this is a zombie thing you uh uh I
want to go to there how do I go into
there I want to be in there is it open
how do I open you I didn't see a key
card slot on the other one there's no
key cards on here I'll just have to make
my way through Oh Oh your suit I thought
you were a guy oh okay
yo clear:both Howard there we go I don't
need that for me let me just go in here
let's see let's see what let's see what
happens ah ah dude no no oh no what
oh no oh no something I don't know
doesn't seem that bad I seem okay so I'm
gonna happen now some gonna happen did
that what did they do I'm not hazmat
suit that's better than gas masks I
don't know either way I got a hazmat
suit now yay
so what did that do let that go
we're due am I gonna die eventually very
slowly and painfully I hope so
what I want to know I want to know what
it did wanted to do I'm guessing that
when I die maybe I'll come back as a
zombie so yeah I gotta like find
something to kill me but there aren't
even any monsters anywhere it's just a
bunch of nothing a whole lotta nothing
what's this keypad I don't have a
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo enter nope
access denied Hotel I guess I'll go down
here let's see what happens let's see
what happens I want some to happen this
is whole videos bench so damn boring
nothing's been going on who watch on I'm
gonna save you know what since this
whole thing is borked anyway I must save
where am i where am i there we go
hello does anyone want to kill me hello
what the what the hell is what oh
whatever
what is that ah what what what ah let's
see you ah
whoa stop
I was a zombie what the hell happened
what was that STP have you ever seen him
before my life I gotta go back but I
saved that forever game it's all right
I'm so stupid
I'm dodo bird what is in here what is in
there what is in there what's in there
what's in there hello what's in there
what's in there
Oh Oh anybody
what are you can't see anything but aah
no aah
who are you I saw a shadow
aah you're not you're not radical Larry
you're gonna hook you get away from me
you son of a [ __ ] where am I
did I turn around oh my god right George
them I am yro where the hell out what
are you what are you huh you're a zombie
you are a zombie
uh mrs. Ellen I'm so boned disease the
zombie disease are you like this army
collector no no no no no no no no no no
no I saw you and nope
no I said no you know yeah yeah maybe
maybe because I got the zombie disease
he does not like me he wants to kill me
maybe you would like help me if I did
not let's guy he's not gonna get me I
know what's best
I hear you no you're not are you go up
go up go up the second my last if you
gonna go through the walls ah
now what okay now we're going up Oh like
what down well congratulations guys
you've seen a bunch of new stuff huh
surprisingly for what I thought that was
gonna be a cadet there could either can
either enter get get outta get a get out
of there there we go okay for what what
I thought was gonna be a bunch of
useless exercises we actually saw some
new stuff and we're infected with the
zombie virus that's good maybe I don't
know so anyway we got a place to pick up
from here so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos it I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
Jenna
while you're good
good
my barrel
door door door door door
get out here fine